tutors have a valueable place in EDH and
here's why a lot of people seem to think
that a deck that does different things
every game is the EDH ideal and while a
bit of variance keeps games interesting
consider this if you happen to draw into
a threat that's way stronger than all
the other ones in your deck for a given
moment you're effectively winning a die
roll and that die roll could determine
the result of a game I find this Bland
there's a reason I'm playing Magic the
Gathering rather than yatsi or bingo in
addition Commander is a social format so
people come into games with expectations
about the decks they're playing against
inconsistent decks are hard to
conceptualize and therefore hard to play
around whereas with a more consistent
deck people can engage with what it's
actually doing which leads to more
Dynamic gameplay now I should mention
tutors aren't the only way of making a
deck consistent you can just run a lot
of cards that do similar things and I
quite enjoy the Simplicity of that
method but some cards just don't have
seven copies in existence or have a more
situational effect and in those cases
running tutors is necessary to maintain
consistency so sorry but yes I will
spend four slots on ways of tutor for
astral slide